やっぱふーんやばいちょいさびさにこっちに出ておりますこんにちははじめ社長ですよ
でここでは昔僕が住んでた家今畑で使ってりーなんですけどもみなさん監視カメラ家に
ある方いらっしゃいますでしょう
なんかもうこの a の住所めっちゃぱれてるんですけどもういいねパルマー氏から
てぃんでどうぞ
んですけれどもそれでもやっぱり女あやしい人が来たり変なの届いたりするんで
やっぱり怖いっちゃ怖いんですよねそういうのをしっかり防犯するためにも一応外に
防犯度はめちゃ高いとしか言えないしてるんですけどもうかそれ防犯カメラとか凄いと
思うんですよという監視カメラなんですけどもいろんな監視カメラがある中でこんなに
小さい感じ亀有マナーでありませんですこちら
俺 b 3日ねー
早く小さい監視カメラも結構あるじゃないですかってこのボールペンの国庫が寝る監視
仮面やってたりとかそういう病監視カメラをたくさんあるんですけどもそういうので手
がしたよくないんですよこれは俺くださいバッテリーも長持ちですね80
これ高画質っていうことですねから amazon でなんとなく見てすごい小さかっ
たんで買ったんですけどもかなり小さかったんでちょっとさっそく開けてみようと思い
ます
汗はヤバイこのサイズ4
大丈夫本当に入っ
ってが初期傷んぽらへん白いけどこれ大丈夫か c 何でもこのサイズで僕も他と比べ
てもこんな名までも本当に合計な9サイズですねめっちゃ小さい以降この3点ですね
ほんとに何か壁とかにくっつける4つケーブル以上ですってすごいスマホと接続したら
スマホで常に確認できるみたいですとさっそくやるだけ
てみましょうかおーなんかすごい色になってきました専用のアプリをダウンロード
しようって
は評価-4
ん
んう
やばいやばいやばい見てんん
まあこれに写ってる奴がここであるんですねほらぼくでしょ
見えたら展示見えます
[音楽]
こいつ何が凄いってこの大きさですよねこのサイズ感よやっぱこれ外し普通に動くって
ことでしょ
ほらもうこれですよこんなサイズ仕掛けるんですよちょっとさっそく同立ちあげて
みようと思いますっ
ターゲットため
この辺に来ると思うでこの部屋の夢と立ちかけてみましょうかこれはぜったいバレ
これはバレエんでしょ
んでこれやばいよこれ本当にバレないよこれええと思っとったん
でもような
[音楽]
me
はちょっと嬉しいな今はそこに仕掛けておりますどうぞ
だめだや晴れ関西6歳のない
持った
決めましたん
ここでしますというわけで監視カメラはここに隠すことにしました
もうソファーのイクってきてマジか分からないと思いますこっからだともう分かりませ
ん
というわけで人は一人の時に何かしでかすと分かりません
というわけで何かたまたまですねこの
一羽の者にと卵ケースがありん
ねっこれてるんだけどたまたま今のサーバーがサービスで僕これを隠しておきました
ん
中には一応現金100万円が入ってますから一応価値もですねはいというわけでヒット
は一人になったときに何をするかは分かりません
この100万円私デッレこそそばに置いておきますと
果たしてターゲッ客版読みして誰もいないときにそりゃクマよ8人ですマーチ
どうするのっぺ見ていっ
思いますけど小型席でもしでわからないと思うんでさすがに大丈夫だと思いますでは
うっかりした
さてと藍鉄当てますトランクに触っています
何してる瞬間移動しましたけど何を撮ったらいいなーっ
やっぱちょっとラグがありますねみたい所が見えなかったりします
さあここからどういう反応するのかひたすらスマホを触っていますさあここで大きな
問題ですソファーが大きすぎて100万円のトランクが見えません
発狂してるな俺は何をしていた自分のイチモツでも見ているのか
まあけどわからない状態になっておりますけど助けられますね
[音楽]
これセグするなんでちょっと
カーテンがそこなんでちょっと叩いてみますね多分上見ると思ってみてください
うわぁ
残念がっ
どうせ寄付あうぞ落とせるよっ
7となってストラッ処刑するかという気にする待機してて
これでとア湖湖畔カベルネにがありませんなわけのわからないに遠隔操作ゲームになっ
てます
ただしもうこれで計最中みるしかないさあ今
100万円のケース手を付けようとしています
さあ an k
立っ
バー
熊井その通りですなぜそんな見た瞬間と200枚とわかったのでしょうか怪しいです
パネルの扱いに慣れているのでしょうが岩手にと200万円を
うわーっと言い方が再びケースに戻す
そしてそのまま
戻すさあいや作っています健介さん山のランドならすぐ切って帰るはずだ
どうする両毛そのカーズの日には肇社長いることが分かっているのでそんなことはでき
ない
ん
た入念に奥にしまってしまうなきょどきょとして弾みましたが経営してるも出せない夏
ならそのカーテン得に始めた人がいるから実験心配です
me
無門に行こうだめですゲームけどヤッター
この部屋に監視カメラがありますどこ
気づきましたか a 1に映る校別がいます
ua うわぁ
ん
弱ないされるその大きさで深めんですか
カメラぶー
左右スバルのんん
打つすごいなきゃですね100マネー失敗でどう失敗とは失敗とあ
[音楽]
からダメなのに懲戒手続きのターゲットいっいきたいとおもいます
客前のわかりやすく置いておきましたか
玉にもつながっている
車間辞めちゃ
ああああああ
自分にどうするのか
いきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[拍手]
協賛します
[音楽]
持っ
astand
[音楽]
ジャズって前に出てきてしまう
ラボナね微妙なんでしょ
ああああああああああああ
持って
またっ
スーパー葛藤を見ていたそう言ってそう
また枚数を数えてしまう
[音楽]
何が入ってるんじゃなきゃいけないとっ
pass 僕ん
ダメって言っ
そあその角度から見るか
知ってしまうから
take me
me
nanoha
[音楽]
wh
します
[音楽]
j 号 hey ああ
あっはい
[音楽]
bl
でしたーー穂先よスターです
ええもうそろそろパパで気づきました
美ママ人気服なかったです